[Music]
all right well hello everybody welcome
to our lecture on viewers choice which
is your opportunity well not necessarily
your opportunity that are here
physically but anyone's opportunity
whether you're very close or very far to
send in your games and have them
analyzed before a very critical crowd so
if you have an interest in having your
game analyzed you can go to st. Louis
chess club org and you'll be prompted to
the programming of viewers choice and
then you can send in your game and you
will very likely get on the show oh I'm
sorry it's info at st. Louis chess club
org there we go
so we ready to get started I think so
now I was reviewing the games that were
sent in by our viewers and I thought
this was probably one of the most
interesting ones and the reason is
because an opening was played that has a
terrible reputation and I really like
the way that Wieck handled this opening
and it made me think hey maybe this
opening isn't that bad of course it's
not that great but when you see a very
nice game it makes you rethink things so
let's get started actually what version
of chess space is this this is probably
12 right first 14 that's good
one of the things I like about chess
base 14 and older is it has this little
training tab that I really like and the
15th version they don't have it anymore
that's kind of a bummer
yeah what do they do without it you have
to do this and eliminate the entire
notation no it's just savagery so okay
let's get started our viewer says hello
my name is AB DeNooyer Gemma from
Algeria and my rapid rating is 1830 this
is my game in a rapid tournament against
and I am Nasser Ali 2,200 elo an African
Junior Champion so definitely playing
against a tough opponent which makes
this game even better
so after d4 Knight f6 III b6 Knight f3
c5 and this is where white really needs
to commit and decide what kind of setup
we're gonna be going for already III was
a pretty big commitment but where this C
pawn is gonna go whether it's gonna go
to c3 or c4 is going to define the
character of the game now when this came
white chose to play c3 anybody know what
this opening is called no yeah the
Colley system and it has I think a an
unfair reputation as just being a bad
choice for white but when you think
about it it's basically a semi Slav with
colors reversed and the semi Slav has a
fantastic reputation as being a great
opening to play with black so does that
one extra move make your position
all of a sudden bad I don't know it's a
very strange I didn't a strange sort of
the way of deciding that an opening is
good or bad just because you're white
and you're not necessarily playing
incredibly aggressive so after a d5
Bishop d3 knight c6 Knight bTW too
Bishop d6 Queenie - now when I studied
the collie and usually I studied it as
black the main moves that white would
play would be castles and after castles
not necessarily Queenie - usually white
wants to play the move D takes c5
because what is the main problem that
white is gonna have to solve in this
position yeah yeah this Bishop on c1
seems to have a pretty glim future ahead
of it because white just has way too
many pawns on dark squares so how are we
gonna get this Bishop out of here not
going to be easy what are some possible
ways to solve this problem
yeah
okay excellent so we can either try to
fianchetto this bishop and put it on b2
or we can try to get this epon out of
III and open up the diagonal for the
bishop to be able to go to g5 in the
semi Slav the most common idea imagine
this position with the colors reversed
is to play the move before and after the
bishop retreats then to play Bishop b2
where it seems like you haven't really
solved all your problems yet because
well you've just put the bishop from one
bad situation into another one because
you're still being blocked by your own
pawns but it turns out that white might
just have enough time to play a 3 and C
4 and if we do that well this Bishop on
b2 is gonna be anything but sound it's
gonna be on a fantastic diagonal so I
really like that idea and if I played
the collie with white which I don't
think I will but if I did I would
probably go for something like this now
in the game white did play D takes e5
but after Bishop takes wait a minute
should go B no sorry in the game instead
of castling white played Queen e2 first
and after castles castles black was able
to play e5 so this is a very important
reaction for black because it doesn't
give white enough time to do what he
wants but D takes e5 and B for it that's
why I'm not entirely sure that this
Queen e2 move was a good use of White's
time I think it's much more important to
get D takes e5 and before it now how
does this change right why can't we play
D takes e5 anyway and after Bishop takes
c5 b4
well first of all oh thank goodness
thank ya
okay does this really work though
right because after B takes c5 he takes
these three Queen takes we have an extra
pawn is why don't we I think so
and we can prepare the c4 pawn break
eventually as well so it for right away
doesn't seem to be the biggest problem
but it is a lingering threat right so
when we retreat our Bishop probably to
d6 hmm
white doesn't have enough time to play
Bishop b2 because now he for definitely
does fork or Bishop and Knight
yeah
okay now that's an interesting idea and
let's say after seat takes e4 very good
because if I simply ignore what you're
doing with Bishop b2 you're probably
gonna take and take on before right and
now black is the one with the extra pawn
so that's an interesting idea and let's
say that after Bishop takes b4 C takes
before II for I protect the b4 pawn with
a three
so what's going on here
yeah and most importantly because I
don't think having an isolated pawn is
necessarily a bad thing in fact I think
that most of the time the isolated pawn
is an asset more than a liability but
having an isolated pawn without the dark
square bishop to create the attacking
chances is a problem so I'm really gonna
miss this Bishop and I'm still going to
get to play Bishop b2 so I'm not
entirely convinced that I would be happy
with blacks position here therefore
after Bishop d6 we renew the threat of
efore and white would have to play efore
here and this looks like a pretty normal
Kali /semi Slav position in fact I think
this is an exact transposition of the
semi Slav only that White has this extra
move Queen e2 actually I'm thinking
maybe this bishop should go to e7
because if b5 then we can go something
like a four and if efore the difference
between having the Bishop on e7 and d6
is that after pawn takes Knight takes
our Bishop isn't being attacked on d6 so
maybe we can try something like 95 so
I'm just thinking out loud but these
look like very interesting positions
especially from White's point of view so
let's see what happened in the game
white played D takes e5 and after Knight
takes e5 Knight takes Bishop takes and E
4 so clearly white is trying to develop
the bishop this way so we've given up on
the idea of putting the bishop on b2
how would you handle this position as
black how would you play this is kind of
a tricky position
any ideas what's the most obvious move
that would that would tempt you here
yeah Bishop g4 okay it looks interesting
and suppose I play the move f3
where
what about this Bishop Bishop e6 and can
I protect that weak diagonal with a move
like f4 yeah and the problem is that you
the problem is if you go to h5 I think I
can just go g4 and after this I can
still go up four yeah yeah you sure can
and where should I go with my queen if I
go to e3
yeah actually that this deformer looks
pretty cool because we can't take on d4
because we lose our queen and if we move
our queen then pawn takes and well let's
see what happens after pawn takes what's
that over here yeah it just wasn't
entirely sure what was going on here
after takes but I guess I can get away
with it right because now everything
everything is hanging I mean you might
just be able to play something like
ninety eight I'm not so sure that's okay
and if I take
yeah after eat a except six if Queen
takes and now I'd take on G for getting
mated be careful so a lot of interesting
complications but I think here we can
actually maybe just go ninety-eight
right where you want to take here okay
and if take on c1 oh very interesting
and now here
I'm gonna I'm not gonna lie to you I am
pretty pretty scared but for the moment
it looks like I'm still alive that looks
interesting so this doesn't allow my
queen to join the defensive effort so I
would have to do something like here but
at the very least you could always just
win a pawn right work takes c5 and I'm
constantly under the threat of checkmate
so this does look good for white t1
Queen Wow
but if rook takes d1 you can't take
because you're getting mated so
interesting idea but
maybe doesn't quite work so after takes
yeah what's your idea yeah Knight takes
e4 oh my goodness and if I go Knight
takes no I think that black has to be
very very careful here
so d4 looks interesting but after Queen
g3 it seems like there's just too much
hanging here right the bishops on g4 and
e5 and maybe later the knight on f6 as
well so who suggested Bishop d6 yeah I
mean yeah if I had to retreat I would
probably go to c7 just to make sure that
this is never that serious
right but this is defended indirectly
right so in any case after Bishop c7 or
Bishop d6 I'm probably gonna have to
play e5 ooh for sure now that looks like
a very good move
Wow looks like I would have to do
something like this
mmm-hmm Bishop b6 King h1
I'm kind of lucky right that after C
takes the three e takes f6 your Bishop
on g4 is trapped because it's pinned h5
and yeah but I can take here right I'm
not getting made it at least not yet so
it looks like black has a lot of
interesting ideas but he's not able to
connect just in time right in order to
make up for these loose pieces on the
kingside so Bishop g4 very interesting
idea I mean it led to some crazy
positions where it seems like white is
holding everything together
the problem for black is that if white
starts mobilizing this these central
pawns with f4 and e5 our pieces are
gonna start getting pushed back so we
need to find a way to restrict White's
play of course I mean the first move
that I would start analyzing would be
well what happens if D takes e4 and here
after Knight takes Knight takes Queen
takes it looks like we're in a little
bit of trouble because the bishop is
hanging in h7 is hanging and if we go
something like g6 after Queen takes
Queen takes Bishop h6 we are in some
pretty hot water
well f6 just here right
right we do not have some very good
options as black here I think the game
is pretty much over so we can't just
play the obvious moves as black that
we've identified what White's main idea
is so that should start guiding us in
the right direction white wants to play
f4 so what can we do
I mean this is a you know pretty simple
threat is there any way that we can
prevent it yeah over over there is that
a hand kid with orange shirt what's your
name
she'll were you raising your hand oh
sorry it all the way in the back
all right so g5 definitely prevents f4
but at what price
yes so King safety is always an the most
important issue and here I'm trying to
think of how I could take advantage of
this I'm wondering if I should go eat
takes d5 or it may be Knight f3 first
where I mean it looks like you would
have to go Bishop g4 but here I can just
play Bishop takes g5 I could but this
might give you enough time to save your
your material right maybe I could just
go age 6
it looks very suspicious in any case
maybe I could go D takes e4 though which
question
okay so going back to this position here
Oh Bishop f4 here okay that's an
interesting idea and well does g3 work
you don't seem to think so
did we go to age six or do we take yeah
and after takes yeah and it turns out
this Bishop on d2 is gonna be in serious
trouble
so g3 doesn't work so Bishop f4 might be
very interesting what about a move like
he five
what's that right riki eight and if
Knight f3 well we would have to trade
these guys off first right and now
Bishop g4 and it also seems like white
is having a little bit of trouble
keeping this Center together so Bishop
before is the move I hadn't thought of
it looks very interesting
it prevents f4 g3 doesn't seem to work
and II five doesn't seem to work so what
do we do I mean if we have to go eat
takes d5 well I have a feeling that
block has to be doing quite well here
right we just go like Queen takes right
and our next move is probably gonna be
something like Bishop g4 or rook e8 it
looks like a very comfortable position
for blacks so this might be a novelty
Bishop f4 because this is a theoretical
position and the move I considered was
simply Queen c7 and the reason I like
this move is because not only does it
prevent f4 but it also attacks h2 and
I'm a big fan of these types of
multi-purpose moves especially when it
comes to defending if you have a choice
to make when you have to defend between
a move that simply defends against your
opponent's threat and in another move
that not only defends against that
threat but creates a threat of your own
should always go with that move because
moves that attack and defend at the same
time are considered multi-purpose moves
and they create problems for your
opponent you don't want your opponent
just to sit there and have all the fun
you want to create some threats to
so we paren deaf for we're attacking h2
what is white gonna do about this right
night a free would make the most sense
because white would be using the same
logic I'm gonna defend against h2 but at
the same time I'm going to attack the
bishop what's that
Bishop g4 looks interesting and I
suppose h3 you want to check here well I
could also move my king and I'm not so
sure this Bishop is entirely happy about
its new
yeah actually I think a very interesting
move here would be the simple D takes e4
because if you go Knight takes e5 after
Queen Tanks I just won upon right this e
for pawn is well protected and it's
going to be even better off once I play
Bishop f5 and rook e8 and if you go
Bishop takes e4 now this doesn't look
like the best arrangement for the Queen
and Bishop so how could we take
advantage of that it's black to move
see movement yeah yeah rookie a and I
think white is busted here we can't move
our bishop away because of the discovery
leading to the loss of our queen and we
can't really move our queen away because
black is just gonna take on e4 and then
win or Queen anyway so I think with some
very simple news Black has been able to
create some very serious problems so in
the Kali if there are any Kali players
out there I would really start
researching possibilities where you take
on c5 and go before because opening up
this efile for black really only helps
black doesn't help white so much and if
you take on c5 you can still play for
efore except you won't have all this
pressure along the e file that we've
been encountering in all these
variations does that make sense yeah
okay so let's see what happened in the
game black played rook e8 right away
white played f4
and black played Bishop to c7 so
everybody like this move everybody agree
with how black has been playing so far
yes okay well I think Bishop c7 is a
very serious blender because yeah it
lets white off the hook right
we can just play e5 yeah I mean white
isn't winning but I think white has put
the worst behind him right we don't have
any more problems along the e-file our
bishop is looking pretty good on d3 our
next move is probably gonna be I don't
know Knight f3 Bishop d2 maybe what
Queen h5 yeah what like white throwing
in Queen h5s yeah the problem is this
Knight isn't really going to move as
long as this a pawn is pinned right so
it's blacks move here actually it's I
don't know what black would do maybe
here but we've already seen this Bishop
run into a lot of trouble on g4 because
then just Queen f2 and the queen is
coming to g3 so I wouldn't be surprised
if White's already better here
so do we have to retreat our Bishop
really the key to determining whether
White's
opening is going to be a success or not
is whether white is going to be able to
get to play e5 so I think this is our
last chance we've discussed several
interesting possibilities to prevent f4
altogether but even after f4 happens we
still have one last exit what could it
be
yeah this looks interesting right
because after F takes e5 we have this
move he takes d3 now I'm still not so
sure about what's going on here because
after well if Queen f2 we can just take
this pawn very important huh okay but
Queen e3 doesn't really threaten
anything right because if this pawn on
e5 is still pinned and we might even be
able to take it down after Knight g4
Knight takes e5 and as a general
consideration whenever you have you know
hopes for an attack and you lose your
light square bishop it's over you know
your attack is very likely going to get
repelled and hopefully you won't have
too many weaknesses as a consequence so
after D takes e4 maybe black white has
to go Knight takes e4
hmm
this doesn't look like such an easy
position either because if we go Bishop
c7 now well nine takes f6 is very
annoying because we can't go Queen takes
do to checkmate and if we have to go G
tags yuck right we don't want to have to
do that to our King
y can just do something like Queen c2 or
Queen f3 and White has to be better here
because this is never good so what can
we do besides retreating right Knight
takes e4 always look for the move that
defends and attacks at the same time
Queen takes e4 fails to Bishop d4 check
and Bishop takes e4 doesn't seem to be
so promising either because well this
Bishop we can just retreat to f6 and at
the very least black should be okay
yeah well ideally what would move the
Queen here right either to c2 or f3
I know maybe White's a tiny bit better
here because of the pressure on b7
although can we do this no right Bishop
takes h7 that doesn't work so we would
probably have to start with something
like rook b8 it's a little bit better
but this is manageable so the last move
would be F takes e5 and this does worry
me a little bit because white still has
the light square bishop pointing at our
Kings side and our Knight is caught
offsides so no actually in the game
black played the move Bishop c7 but it
seems like even with D takes e4 all the
problems aren't solved so maybe it's too
late already maybe the key to this
variation is to prevent f4 once that the
pawn gets to have four things start
getting out of hand so black played
Bishop c7 and after E 5 d4
now white played Knight e4 very
interesting move
so trying to eliminate the defender on
f6 and that way unleash the power of
this battery along the b1 h7 diagonal
black took on e4 and after Bishop takes
e4 I would have been very tempted to
play Queen takes but what happens here
yeah f5 and black is able to shut it
down just in time right the Queen has to
move and here maybe we can go dc-3 first
or simply Bishop e6 because if Queen
takes b7 d takes c3 looks like a problem
so it's important not to get a little
bit too excited right with Auto
checkmate yeah and then all of a sudden
f5 you're like oh that didn't work so
white played Bishop takes and black went
Queen e7 which looks a little bit too
passive to me
what would have happened if f5 anyway
if f5 worked so well against queenie 4
then is it that much worse against
bishop on e4 yeah yeah what's that yeah
okay right because if Queen takes you
take on h7 right but what happens if I
go here
well rook e1 I'm just gonna take the
bishop on e4 what's that
f7 might work as well I was actually
thinking about going Queen here well but
then if you move the King I could even
allow myself the luxury of this
in-between move and take your Bishop and
it's over so it would seem like Bishop
e6 is a forest what
takes on c5 maybe Bishop yeah Bishop d6
this looks a little bit tricky what's
that somebody in the back yeah all of a
sudden these bishops are looking pretty
good yeah do you like blacks position
here oh yeah but I think here maybe we
should try something like queen d3
trying to target this pawn on h7 Queen
h5 Queen c4 Bishop e6 Bishop b6 Queen
age 5 okay it might be right so let me
just do this because it's free and now
g6 but now Bishop takes you say actually
I like that Queen h5 idea kind of
stopped here with Queen takes e5 Bishop
d6 and got spooked by the bishops but
Queen H - it's like game over so yeah
very nice there's probably people with
an engine checking and all this stuff
we're talking about we must be so so
wrong but it makes sense that's good
enough
about what we're gonna go back to that
right now I think this might be a very
much more efficient way for white to
play right because King takes his
forests and what's your follow up now
yep
so if if g6 you probably take here and
that looks devastating if King g8 you'll
probably just take the bishop so the
only move seems to be Bishop g6 maybe so
we're yeah we're down at pawn and our
King is just dancing in the middle of
the board that can't be good because
here well maybe cuz here a check and
then you can just take right page one is
better yeah but maybe d3 here
we're beat beware of your back rank
yeah rook d1 also looks a little bit
dangerous right because of Czech and
after King H one week and this pawn is
not being threatened right now and the
problem is this Bishop yeah I think you
should play Bishop d2 but still this
looks fairly active right for black I
don't think this is so easy right you go
here
f-five probably check here takes takes
and that would be so happy oh I block
the check and then I get checked me so I
probably have to keep the position
closed right G fine
we can see five you're just helping my
king where Queen see five King g8 well I
I don't I don't want to move my bishop
cuz I'm hoping that you'll forget about
this idea the bishop is hang that is
true that's that's very very true and I
guess there's not much I can do about it
yeah that works
so f6 going for the glory so if I take
here you want to go Bishop takes g5
right and now Bishop h6 looks pretty
devastating so hmm so you want to go g6
but now Bishop takes right yeah this
doesn't look that great what's that
hmm
so maybe rookie 2 is just not not going
to cut it and if we go something like
Queen d6 first trying to prevent this f5
idea
I don't know about this though because
can I can I still try to play with the
compensation because it if tags takes
you go rook d1
yeah the only thing that that I was kind
of concerned about was if I go rookie to
now I didn't want to give this bishop a
nice square but Lodi - maybe just here
yeah mmm I know it's very suspicious
because if I do something like this you
could probably do check here and wait a
minute am I just winning the pond
I mean if I get this pawn it's over so
maybe we should throw in the check
before hand right have you check King
here now d2 this looks very good for
black
I don't know that pawn on d2 looks like
a nightmare because the rooks coming to
either da torre eight and then the
bishop can come to e3 so rook d1 rook
the eight
how does white continue let's say we go
something like h4 just maybe well is it
because at least h4 you know it gets our
pawns moving a little bit faster
Brooke d3 and what's that
I mean I think the only counterplay
white might have is based on some kind
of f5 idea right that's an impression
I'm getting maybe we should even
consider playing up five here I don't
know but still after takes takes King g8
you've got some serious
what counterplay
well is rookie one a threat what if I go
what if I go h4
something like that no
yeah yeah I mean doesn't look so great
for white anymore so this is definitely
blacks best chance just allowing this
pawn to live on d3 can give black a lot
of counter play which is more than black
was hoping to get in that position
anyway so maybe f7 works but I think
this idea
Adie right but behind
Adie is what a sheesh right yeah okay
but the idea that Ashish said of playing
Queen C for Queen c5 and Queen h5 seems
pretty interesting too so let's see what
actually happened in the game black
played Queen e7 and now after cd4 CD for
Queen d3 all right so now we not only
have the problem of h7 but also d4
although we can't really take on d4
right away because of Bishop d6 so black
played h6 Bishop d2 Bishop b6
rook a e1 and this reminds me a little
bit of the Scotch opening I know is a
completely different opening but White's
main idea in the Scotch this would be
like a scotch players dream position is
to move your en F ponts up as much as
you can so here I think White's just
preparing to go f5 after which these two
bishops are going to exert tremendous
pressure on the Kings side so well I
play Queen d8
and after f5 the question is what
happens after rook takes e5 what do you
guys think white had in mind here
bishop white bishop b7 okay
let's say rook takes and let's say yeah
I'll take what the King yeah it was
better here yeah so this didn't really
work out so well to white but no white
played a very interesting pawn sacrifice
here and followed up with the move f6 so
we gave up this important ePHI pawn but
at the very least now both bishops are
in the game
we're threatening Bishop h7 winning the
rook and we're also threatening to strip
the black king of all its protection so
I think this was really the the finest
point in the game for white so black
retreated with the rook rook e6 but now
I think things take a turn for the worst
right Bishop h7 King h8 pawn takes King
takes rook takes a 6 Bishop takes a 6
and Bishop efore so we're still down
upon but I wish I was so lucky to be
down upon like this in all my games
because this pawn on h6 is going to come
under a lot of pressure this queen is
coming to g3 and we're even really need
to take this pawn right away well I
guess after Queen g3 the King has to
move to a square where it can't protect
the pawn and we can include our Bishop
in the attack so I play Queen d6
stopping Queen g3
and after Queen f3 yeah f5 ouch
Queen h5 what was that yeah I think the
game is basically over after a white
found this very nice f6 move it really
highlights how relative material is in
chess you know hey I see a lot of
players and a lot of my students get
completely blinded by material thinking
it's the most important variable in
chess but it's just one variable it is
one very important variable but it's not
the only one I would say that you have
King safety material pawn structure
piece placement or piece activity
whatever you want to call it and those
four variables should always be on your
checklist right once you have a material
advantage the worst thing you can do is
just keep thinking okay more material I
need more material no you've already
checked off material you've checked it
off your your list now you need to focus
on your King safety your piece activity
your pawn structure and you want to keep
a balanced list you don't want to overly
focus on one at the expense of the
others so there are some players that
are too solid they don't care about
material they just think about their
pawn structure and their King safety and
maybe they'll just get too passive in
terms of their piece placement for
example or they won't capture a pawn
when they should so these are all
variables that are in a constant flux
but one of the most common mistakes you
can make is when you already have a
material advantage to keep focusing on
expanding that material advantage so
I agree I think black is making some
desperate moves here the game is over
after Queen takes f5 White's not even
down material now so he gets a free
attack and at this point black simply
resigned
it seems resigned yeah so we're
threatening Queen age 7 now why did
black resign what's wrong with Bishop g6
queen g4 I like that move but still are
we what are we threatening Queen takes
and then what Queen here and then King
h8
this was a blitz game I keep playing I
don't know what what if I go here or
what if I throw in this check first oh
that's that's not a good idea I was
gonna think Oh powerful pawn on d3 now
after Bishop c3 it's probably over so
I'll let I'll keep that pawn on d4 so
I'll go rook the eight
Brook where oh that's a cool idea
let's take a look this also looks quite
promising
yeah I don't really have a good place
for my queen maybe I have to go like
yeah and now this is gonna be even
stronger so yeah all of these ideas look
pretty devastating so blacks position is
hopeless resigned maybe he could have
waited a move but it's over okay so a
very nice game I definitely encourage
anybody out there that's watching the
show and would like to have their game
analyzed to send it in and we'll do our
best to get to it how are we doing with
time Bensimon okay so I should probably
wrap it up huh okay this is me wrapping
it up so thanks for coming and I'll be
seeing around I'm gonna be here at the
club for the next couple of weeks so if
you have any questions just catch me and
we can talk all right okay thank you
[Music]
you